مرحبا
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي مالك
كانوا في المدرسه يلقبوني البدوي طبعا انا
متاكد ان الكثير من الحضور اليوم معه لقب
لقبين وماسكه معه الان
طلابنا اليوم بيعانوا من ضغوطات شديده
داخل المدرسه
ضغوطات انتقلت من برا على المدرسه معه
للصف
فهل نحن اليوم متاكدين من اللي يتعلموا
ابناءنا داخل المدرسه
طبعا المدرسه هي اول مكان
بيتعرف فيه الطفل على لهجته على لغته على
دينه مبادئه على العادات السيئه والكويسه
كل حاجه وبيع
كسها مهارات بيتعلمها في المدرسه بتبقى
معه العمر كله
[موسيقى]
طيب خلوني اقول لكم ايش اللي موجود اليوم
في المدرسه
في المدرسه يوجد اليوم الكثير من التنمر
الكثير من العنف اللفظي والجسدي
وحالات للاسف تحرش وتمييز عنصري
هذا كلها يمر فيها ابنائنا
اخي اختي ابنك بنتك كلنا كل ابناءنا
الاطفال بيمر فيها في اول باول عمره
طيب
[موسيقى]
واحد ممكن يقول عادي خليه يشتحط كذا
ويقويه يتكلم لكن لا
طبعا عيالكم صوره
يعني انا مستحيه اوريكم
هذا انا
متنمر سابق وهذا صاحبي ايهاب
طبعا ايهاب بخير ما تقلقوش اموره طيبه
بس انا نفسي كذا تخيل ايش يهاب يحس يا اخي
بعد الدرع من وجهي هذا يا اخي
اصبر بنشيل الصوره
ايهاب بخير خلص الماجستير واموره طيبه
ويشتغل
[موسيقى]
طيب
ايش ليش ليش نبدا من المدرسه ما هو نحن
كلنا شباب كبار بالسن كلنا بنعاني من هذه
الضغوطات ليش المدرسه
المدرسه بطبيعه الحال لها سلطه على الطفل
لها سلطه مصدقه كل حاجه انا بتعلمها
بالمدرسه ما انتم تقولوا لي انها صحيحه
وكذلك ايضا في مهارات تسمى بمهارات الذكاء
العاطفي الاجتماعي
هذه المهارات لا تتطور عند الانسان الا في
بدايه حياته عندما يكبر شويه بسن للاسف
يصعب تطويرها باختصار ايش هذه المهارات
القدره على التحاور وقدره على فض النزاع
حل المشاكل
الانفعالات فهم النفس وفهم الاخر
نحن ننسى ابنائنا ما نعلمهم هذه الاشياء
للاسف في المدرسه وللاسف ايضا بنعلمهم
اشياء اخرى ممكن تضره ممكن تخليه يشوف
العالم كله بلون واحد
طيب ايش الحل كله رغي رغي رغي ايش الحل
في حاجات كثيره ممكن نشتغلها نحن كافراد
طبعا دائما نحن ما بنقول التعليم الواحد
بيتبادر الى ذهنه انه يلا كراسي طلاء ابني
صف صحيح هذا كله مهم
[موسيقى]
ولكن في اشياء ايضا اكثرها اهميه او بنفس
الاهميه وهي انه نكون متواجدين في المدرسه
نقلل من الضغوطات التي يمر بها الطالب
نقلل من تحرش او التنمر او التمييز الذي
يمر بها الطفل
طيب انا كذلك يعني فكرت بشغلتين وانا
متاكد اذا كلنا اليوم فكرنا بنجيب حلول
اكثر بنساعد فيها ابنائنا الشغله الاولى
اللي ممكن نفيد فيها ابنائنا اذا كنا
صادقين واذا كنا عارفين ايش ننتقل
للمستقبل اللي هي المشاركه المجتمعيه في
التعليم الكومينتي بارتسبيشن
في معهد ام اي تي وحاصله على جائزه نوبل
في الاقتصاد
قامت في حديث في منصه
اسم الحديث تجربه مجتمعيه لمكافحه الفقر
كانت التجربه هي لدعم التعليم دعم مو
شغلات كثيره
من شغلات دعموها وهي
ملابس للاطفال حلو
وجبات رواتب مدرسين ايضا
وسووا حاجه رابعه او اكثر من حاجه بالاصح
وسووا حاجه اللي هي المجتمع باهميه
التعليم
طبعا هذا كله كان مفيد لكن لما نوعوا
المجتمع باهميه التعليم كانت النتيجه
ساحقه واضعاف مضاعفه بقيه الاشياء الاخرى
اربعين سنه تراكميه من التعليم فقط روح قل
في المجتمع روح للمدرسه ادعم ابنك كيف
يدرس وكانت هذه النتيجه
طيب يعني نحاول نسوي مثل ما سويت بقيه
الدول نروح المدرسه نشوف ابناءنا ايش
يدرسوا ايش يتعلموا من ايش يعانوا صديق
ليا يقول لي ابني كل ما هو الصباح يعني
يقول له روح المدرسه يبكي يقول لي ما
باروحش فاساله ايش السبب يعني انت عارف
السبب قال لي كسول لا
يا بني ادم في واحد حامل له عصا يمكن داخل
المدرسه روح شوف ايش فيه كم مرات زرت
المدرسه قال لي لا ما اروحش المدرسه اوصله
لا هذه هي الاشكاليه ابنائنا بيعانوا من
هذه الاشياء
ابنائنا بيعانوا منذ الضغوطات
ضروري نساعدهم غير هكذا هذا كله بيستمر
وبيكبر معه
الى سن متقدم
طيب نحن اليوم كمجتمع موجودين داخل
المدرسه ايش مهمتنا مثل ما قلت لكم نقلل
فقط الضغوطات على الطفل فقط تعليم بيجي
تعليم بيجي يا سر متحدث الاول تعلم لحاله
تعليم بيكي
مهمتنا نقلل الضغوطات على الطالب
نقلل النسب التنمر تمييز العرف
هذه هي مهمتنا كمجتمع
طيب بسالكم سؤال
من سمع من قبل
بمجلس الاباء والامهات يرفع يده
طيب
من حضر اخر شهر اجتماع اخر شهر
ما ناقد عرفت انه قله النسبه شفتوا كيف
طيب اللي مش عارف
مجلس الاباء والامهات هو عباره عن تجمع
داخل المدرسه يجمع بين اولياء الامور
ويجمع بين القيادات المدرسيه لحل مشاكل
المدرسه
يعني انا انت كلنا داخل هذه المدرسه مع
قيادات المدرسه بنحل مشاكلها بنشوف ايش
المشاكل وحسب ملاحظاتي
بشتغل في التعليم يعني اكثر المدارس اللي
كنت بزورها وبشوفها يعني حلوه كذا الوان
وكذا في حيويه داخلها تاني المجتمع داخل
والمدرسه
اللي كان تدخل من البوابه تحس انك شيء غلط
روح انت على طول قرب واسال المدير متى
تجتمع انت والاولياء اولياء الامور او
مجلس الاباء يقول لك اصلا ما فيش
قرب بسال
طيب اذا هذا هو هذه الاشياء يعني الحاجات
البسيطه ما هيش فلوس مش دائما صرف الفلوس
فقط تواجد
طيب هذه الشغله اللي انا مثلا فكرت فيها
وكذا وايش غيره
الشغله الثانيه اضافه الى وجود المجتمع
داخل المدرسه هي المدرس
المدرس يوصل رساله ساميه لكن للاسف نحن
حطينا اهم شخص في تكوينه اي مجتمع في
مضمار سباق بلاك بلا تدريب وقلنا له انطلق
صعبه
ونشتيه ياهي الاجيال قادره على التعايش
قادره على المساواه الصانعه للسلام حاملا
الرايه يعني قويه واثقه من نفسها
خلوني اعطي لكم نبذه بسيطه عن مشكله
المدرس
المدرسين القدماء
المؤهلين المخضرمين وصلوا الى سن التقاعد
وجزء كبير منهم بدا يتقاعد
اقاقيل جديد متحمس يشتي يدرس لكن مع
الاوضاع اللي حصلت في البلد
هذا الجيل لم يحظى بالتدريب الكافي ولا
التاهيل الكافي وفوق هذا للاسف راتبه يمكن
احيانا ما يكفيش
ثم تخيل الان راتبه مايكل فيش وعنده يعني
احيانا التدريب او التاهيل الكافي للسيطره
على الطفل لعلاج يعني
للتعامل معه
فوق هذا وهذا
بيشتغل دوام ثاني عشان يغطي احتياجاته
شغله اخرى قد جنبها او احيانا بيجيب مدرس
بديل او احيانا عندنا عكس في المدرسين
بنجيب المدرسين متطوعين اذا صار عندنا في
المدرسه اليوم مدرس مضغوط مدرس بديل مدرس
متطوع
وداخل الصف 120 طالب
كيف يسوي هذا يعني ايش الساحر هو صعبه
يعني انه يدير هذا الطفل ويقوم اخلاقه
ويحافظ على انفعالاته وما يحاولش انه يتعب
عليه طيب اذا برضو رغي كيف نحن نحلها هذه
المشكله معنا شغلتين هنا وهذا اللي فكرت
فيها انا والباقي عليكم تفكروا فيها
الشغله الاولى علينا كمجتمع ان نعيد
للمدرس هيبته نكون موجودين معه واقفين
خلفه يعني يعرف انه قاره الولي الامر الكل
متواجد معه يطمئن
المدرس اليوم ما بيتعرضش فقط لانتهاكات
خارج المدرسه بيتعرض لها داخل المدرسه
وانتم متخيلين ان الطفل اللي مفروض انه
يشوف قدوته امامه هكذا يعني وصورته بتتكسر
ايش اللي عكسناه نحن للطفل هذا وايش
متوقعين منه بعد عشر 15 سنه يعني
طيب هذه اللي علينا نحن كمجتمع ايش باقي
على المدرس
المدرس ايضا هو جزء من المدرسه وهو بطبيعه
الحال مصدق عند الطفل فعليه ان يحاول ان
لا يقلب الضغوطات الخارجيه الا يقلب
التحيزات التميز العنف في الصف معه للطفل
الا يعني طفل هذه مهمه المدرس اللي يقدر
يسويها الان وان يصبر لانه بامانه انا
اشوف انه اشقع شخص هو هذا الشخص اللي
بيخرج باقل تقدير مادي من الصباح الى
الظهر عشان يوصل رساله عشان يعمل همنا نحن
كلنا كابراد هذا اهم شخص
فانت مهمتك يا مدرسنا ان تحاول ان لا تقلب
ما يدور خارج هذه المدرسه للمدرسه وان
تعرف تعرف ان المعلومه الخاطئه الواحده
معلومه خاطئه واحده عشر معلومات صحيحه ما
بتصلحها
اذا اليوم
مدرسه فيها مجتمع
فيها مدرس
مدرسه امنه ابنك اخوك اختك بقوم الصباح من
بدري بيروح للمدرسه
يتعلم فيها ما يلزمه من السوشيال سكيلز او
المهارات الذكاء العاطفي الاجتماعي بيتعلم
ما يلزمه لبقيه المستقبل انا متاكد ان
الوضع يكون مختلف
انا اشوف انه نحن اليوم كلنا كافراد ضحايا
تعليم ومدرسه
مننا من نقر
ومننا صار الى ما صار اليه
المبنى اللي بيهتد بنعمله بنبنيه المؤسسه
اللي بتتكسر بنعيد والسياسه دائما فن
الممكن حاجه واحده فقط
اذا سبناها
ما بنقدر نعيدها وهو شاب في المستقبل
مش عارف كيف يحل مشاعره مش عارف كيف ينضبط
كيف يسيطر على انفعالاته غير قادر على حل
المشكله اللي امامه نسيناه اليوم ما
علمناهوش نهج التعايش في المدرسه شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]